all right uh i i did not plan to talk
more about sarah palin i know many of
you were hoping david never mentions
sarah palin again um a couple months ago
one month ago i guess six weeks ago
sarah palin said she would only get
vaccinated over her dead body she now
has coveted and sarah palin's defamation
suit against the new york times was
scheduled to start this week and it's
been delayed because she has coveted we
learned that she has covered sometime
after saturday saturday she was out at a
restaurant in manhattan we then learned
she has covered
and yesterday she was out again sarah
palin is out at restaurants with kovid
and there's a bunch of different
elements to this freedom news reports
that sarah palin is seen dining at a
manhattan restaurant while waiting for
her trial to resume this was published
last night she was seen dining and
speaking with patrons at elio's italian
restaurant in the upper east side of
manhattan
following her positive covet test just
two days prior
she is seen with her group seated in the
outdoor area
um
she's just
going out to eat i guess with kovid
let's take a look at a little bit of
this and i'll describe what's going on
in a moment
[Music]
so if you're only listening today and
not watching she's in one of these kind
of like indoor outdoor or outdoor indoor
things she's walking around
um
she's uh you know knocking on the
outdoor indoor kind of tent type thing
that that is going on there
um and she uh she has coveted so there's
a couple of different interesting things
here one is
there are vaccine requirements in
manhattan for going to restaurants
indoors and from what we know on
saturday she was indoors so the first
question is is she lying about being
unvaccinated she's actually unvaccinated
she's actually vaccinated claiming she's
unvaccinated but showed her vaccine
thing or
did this restaurant not actually check
it meaning they're violating the rules
in new york
we don't really we don't really know
the second part though and the bigger
part is
we're talking about saturday to
wednesday right so
she was out to eat saturday she tested
positive presumably sunday or later
she hasn't isolated for the required
five days she instead went out to dinner
and
this is completely irresponsible in
every way just just there's no there's
no math that says this makes sense she
was out saturday so presumably she
wasn't positive then
we learned she was positive sunday so
that gets a sunday monday tuesday
wednesday you're talking about 72 hours
later and she's already back out at a
restaurant so this we knew that we we've
known for a long time she's a disgusting
person
we've known for a long time that she's
probably a liar and whether she's lying
about the vaccination or we don't we
don't know but she's told all sorts of
other lies in the past
but she's just out with covid in new
york city and uh awaiting her defamation
trial now one other thing i do want to
mention and this is just kind of this
doesn't have anything to do with sarah
palin
i genuinely don't know at this point you
know that it's like
it's outdoor indoor they've placed an
indoor thing outdoors uh it's it's all
enclosed in plastic with heat and i
guess it's like slightly open i really
don't care like i go to this stuff as
well
but to some degree i find it funny when
it's like we've basically taken indoor
dining and put it outdoors sometimes
there's a completely and it's completely
enclosed
um i i just don't know you know i don't
know what the risk level is and how it
varies in these different things i'm not
doing actual indoor dining right now as
i've said many times
but sometimes i look at the outdoor ones
and i'm like i'm basically indoors i'm
just
i'm i'm outside of the restaurant but
i'm clearly indoors in some kind of
enclosed thing
who knows who knows but that's what's
going on sarah palin out with covid out
on the town one of our sponsors is
kamikoto who creates elegant high-end
japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from honshu japan
i'm a huge fan of japanese kitchen
knives i've owned a bunch of different
sets none as nice as my kamikodo knives
made with real japanese steel
every knife comes in a beautiful heavy
duty ash wood box and a lifetime
guarantee you can get them in several
different sets and combinations kamikoto
makes it really easy to figure out which
one is best for you you can also pick up
one of kamikoto's sharpening wet stones
which are designed especially for
kamikodo knives i've had an excellent
experience using kamikodo knives in my
kitchen at home it just feels
comfortable in your hand the mechanics
of slicing with high quality japanese
knives like these feel really really
nice and right now kamikoto is having a
huge valentine's day sale
you get 50 off on top of their other
offers when you go to kamikodo.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below